y en directo a América hacemos un repaso
A qué están diciendo los medios
internacionales y lo hacemos con nuestra
periodista Rosa Pérez más deu Rosa
bienvenida de nuevo aquí un placer estar
con usted Igualmente María Clara
Comencemos hablando de jacira porque hay
un artículo bastante interesante que
habla de las lecciones sobre la guerra
moderna que nos está diciendo este
artículo bueno en primer lugar empieza
con una advertencia señalando que las
lecciones de la guerra en Ucrania
todavía se debaten dice después de todo
todavía no hay un ganador claro de este
conflicto sin embargo esta guerra ha
acelerado tendencias que ya se
observaban en conflictos anteriores Y
que pueden indicar Cómo sucederán
guerras futuras usted bien lo dijo la
guerra en Ucrania está mostrando como
unas nuevas tendencias se aceleran pero
concretamente son esas tendencias rusas
por un lado dice la importancia de la
guerra de informativa particularmente en
el campo de las redes sociales no entre
otros tipos de videos hemos visto muchas
imágenes de soldados en el campo de
batalla tanto de un bando como del otro
pero particularmente este texto hace
referencia a los videos de soldados
ucranianos que intentan a intimidar a
soldados rusos no Y particularmente en
este texto se señala que el efecto
psicológico de mostrar a los rusos que
les pasará si se alistan en las fuerzas
armadas es un aspecto que los oficiales
militares llaman guerra
híbrida por otro lado las imágenes del
sufrimiento de civiles también señala
han facilitado la legitimación
finalmente de la ayuda occidental
millonaria a Ucrania y en esa guerra
híbrida no solo se trata de guerra de
información como usted lo mostraba con
los vídeos sino también la tradicional
relativa a las municiones sin embargo
también hay una tendencia en el cambio
del mercado del armamento exactamente
señala este texto que las armas de
precisión como serían drones misiles de
largo alcance sistemas de cohetes
móviles pueden llegar a sustituir en
ciertos en ciertos contextos a la
incursión de un Batallón y que esto ha
favorecido al lado más débil en términos
de fuerza humana no de personal que
sería a Ucrania que como decíamos no
cuenta con menos recursos humanos Pero
ha contado con muchísimo armamento de
tecnología punta occidental y Andreas
iliopoglos un experto militar citado en
este texto dice nuestro miedo al
principio de la guerra era que los
ejércitos acorazados de Putin arrasarán
Ucrania Pero esto no sucedió la javelina
y otras armas similares exterminaron los
tanques esto es un nuevo tipo de guerra
no podríamos haberlo predecido y para
mezclar una cosa con la otra recordemos
que la santa javelina esta imagen de una
virgen con esta con la jabelina no este
sistema antimisiles de fabricación
estado con el que cuenta el ejército
ucraniano se ha convertido en un icono
no de la resistencia ucraniana sobre
todo una imagen muy compartida en redes
sociales Pero eso sí señala este experto
el movimiento se ha vuelto más difícil
todo lo que se mueve es golpeado el
campo de batalla se ha vuelto
transparente pero la velocidad la
facilidad de maniobra la protección y La
potencia de un tanque no se Iguala con
ningún otro sistema es en relación a la
guerra moderna tan un espacio tan
vigilado con tantos sistemas aéreos
entre otras cosas pero la dominancia
todavía de los tanques un armamento más
tradicional y este experto en el
artículo que usted nos está mostrando
también afirma que toda Ucrania se
convirtió en un campo de batalla Sí dice
que la sociedad ucraniana toda está en
guerra que el campo de batalla no es
lineal No es tan fácil a pesar de todo
delimitar una línea de frente donde
afecte o no la guerra que la distinción
entre civiles y militares ya no existe
era la tendencia que ya se observaba en
conflictos anteriores pero que ya ha
alcanzado otras magnitudes Y por último
señala como Ucrania ha aprendido el
poder de las alianzas que si bien la
intención de Rusia en esta guerra era
intentar evitar que Ucrania se uniera a
la otan a pesar de que no esté bajo el
paraguas del artículo 5 no de la alianza
la que defiende el artículo que recoge
la defensa mutua Pues a la práctica tal
y como dijo dimitroculeva el Ministerio
el ministro de Exteriores ucraniano en
octubre Ucrania ya es parte de la
seguridad Euro atlántica Y a propósito
de esta guerra Rosa la agencia
norteamericana ap publicó unas
fotografías de la guerra que nunca había
revelado hasta ahora cuáles son
exactamente Y es que este artículo
coordinado por Sara di Lorenzo señala
que los fotógrafos los fotoperiodistas
en la Guerra de Ucrania pueden sacar en
una semana Tantos tantas fotografías
como sacaban en un año en la guerra de
Bosnia en este caso hacen una de 28
fotografías de las que hemos destacado
tres no ustedes las pueden ver en su
totalidad en la web de apet la primera
que hemos querido seleccionar es una
foto de Emilio morenatti que se publicó
la cual se publicó una foto parecida en
la 25 de febrero Un día después de la
invasión a rusa de Ucrania la que
estamos viendo aquí detrás en la foto
que fue publicada y que dio la vuelta al
mundo la mujer se tapaba la boca y tenía
los ojos cerrados no esta fotografía es
justo del instante posterior y es lo que
nos dice este artículo no que muchas de
las fotografías descartadas eran del
momento previo o del momento justo de
después del que se utilizó para mostrar
al mundo en este caso morena te dice que
en este momento fue consciente del
riesgo a la digamos que se enfrentaba la
población civil ucraniana otra que hemos
seleccionado es la de un niño entre las
ruinas de Natasha pisarenko la que se
publicó el 31 de marzo mostraba al niño
corriendo para dice la fotógrafa como
los niños a veces logran evadirse de la
guerra mientras en esta en que el niño
está detenido dice como los niños a
pesar de todo no también buscan la forma
de dar sentido a lo que pasa a su
alrededor a pesar de que la realidad sea
tan dura como una guerra Y por último
hemos seleccionado una fotografía de
bernat Armand con el pie de foto Elena
llora junto al cuerpo de su esposo
alexey en El fotógrafo dice que en un
primer momento decidió no publicarla
porque la consideraba demasiado fuerte y
que ahora agradeció la oportunidad de
compartir esta historia parece que uno
de los debates más recurrente para los
fotoperiodistas es elegir En qué punto
las fotos deben ser macabras o no O no
en que donde encontrar el equilibrio
entre Mostrar el horror sin hacer que
nosotros apartemos la mirada una difícil
labor de los fotorreporteros Rosa y
También aprovecho para recordarles a
nuestros televidentes que mañana 24 de
febrero en France 24 tendremos 3
especiales sobre el primer año de la
guerra en Ucrania
serán a las 7 de la mañana hora Bogotá
quito Lima a las dos de la tarde y a las
siete de la noche los invitamos a que se
conecten con nosotros Rosa gracias por
toda esa información Igualmente María
Clara hasta mañana